In our previous lesson,
we got an overview of the iterative QMV process of analysis.
And how it can be described as a way to go about solving data modeling problems.
In this lesson, we dive deep into a specific problem.
We devote the entire lesson to understanding an individual's Twitter usage
pattern and how it is influenced by the relationships as well as other factors.
This lesson is all about the impact of data and how the quality and
quantity of data can impact the models we build.
We try to gain a sense of how much data is enough to
say something with any accuracy.
Once we've got data we can use, we think about how to determine what to
pay attention to within data, otherwise known as the feature selection problem.
Lastly, once we know what to pay attention to,
we learn how to detect certain kinds of structure that may exist in our data,
and what types of models are motivated by them.